What's the point of travel?
It's to help make us into better people.
It's a sort of therapy.
Without anything mystical being meant by this, all of us are, in one way or another,...
...on what can be termed an "inner journey."
That is, we're trying to develop in particular ways.
In a nutshell, the point of travel is to go to places...
...that can help us in our inner evolution.
The outer journey should assist us with the inner one.
Every location in the world contains qualities...
...that can support some kind of beneficial change inside a person.
In an ideal world, travel agencies will be manned by a new kind of psychotherapist.
They'd take care not just of the flights and the hotels,...
...they'd start by finding out what was wrong with us and how we might want to change.
We need to relearn how to be ambitious about travel,...
...seeing it as a way of helping us to grow into better versions of ourselves.